>> IN IMMUNEO COMPROMISED
PEOPLE, TRANSPLANT PATIENTS,
CANCER PATIENTS, ET CETERA.
IT’S A GOOD DECISION.
IT TELLS US A LOT ABOUT WHERE
THE SCIENCE AND DATA ARE HEADING
AND I DO BELIEVE A STAGE OF
BROADER APPLICATION.
IT’S NOT THAT UNCOMMON.
I THINK WE ALWAYS HAD THE
EXPECTATION THAT THIS MIGHT BE
THE CASE.
MARIA: FORMER COMMISSIONER OF
THE FDA PRAISING THE FDA’S
DECISION TO AUTHORIZE COVID
BOOSTERS FOR PEOPLE WITH
WEAKENED IMMUNE SYSTEM.
JOINING ME PRESIDENT OF OF MODER
STEPHEN HOGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPENDING
THE TIME WITH US.
YOU HEARD DR. HAHN, TELL US
ABOUT THE NEED FOR A BOOSTER,
HOW MUCH PROTECTION DOES THE
MODERNA VACCINE GIVE US AND WILL
WE ALL NEED A BOOSTER AT SOME
POINT?
DOCTOR: WELL, IT’S IMPORTANT TO
CONTEXTUALIZE THIS IN THE PHASE
OF DELTA VARIANT AND THE SURGES
THAT WE HAVE SEEN.  YOU LOOK
OVER THE COURSE OF THE SUMMER, I
THINK WE’VE ALL BEFORE SURPRISED
BY THE STEPS THE VIRUS HAS TAKEN
TO EVOLVE AND GET, MUCH, MUCH
BETTER IN THE FORM OF DELTA AND
INFECTING PEOPLE AND THAT’S
REALLY WHAT’S DRIVING THE SURGE
RIGHT NOW.
SO THE VACCINES ARE REALLY
EFFECTIVE AND THAT’S THE GOOD
NEWS, IN FACT, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BREAK DOWN OF CASES, STILL
ALMOST OVERWHELMINGLY THESE
CASES ARE IN THE UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE.
THE NUMBER ONE THING THAT WE
HAVE TO DO IS THOSE FOLKS
VACCINATED BUT AS YOU SAID,
MARIA, THERE’S BREAKTHROUGH
COULD START TO HAPPEN WITH THE
VACCINE AND DELTA POSES A
SUBSTANTIAL THREAT TO ALL OF THE
VACCINES AND THE DURABILITY OF
THE IMMUNITY.
MARIA: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
BREAKTHROUGH CASES.
ANECDOTALLY I HAVE A FEW FRIENDS
WHO HAVE BEEN VACCINATED AND GOT
COVID ANYWAY?
DOCTOR: I THINK DR. HAHN SAID IT
WELL.
IT’S NOT SURPRISING THAT
IMMUNITY WOULD DECLINE OVER TIME
OR RESPIRATORY VIRUS.  YOU THINK
ABOUT IT IT’S NOT THAT DIFFERENT
HAND WHEN YOU GET THE COMMON
COLD.
WE ARE USED TO GETTING THE
COMMON COLD A COUPLE OF AND
SOMETIMES IT CAN BE A SEVERE
COLD AND THAT’S REALLY ACTUALLY
A COUSIN TO CORONAVIRUS THAT’S
CIRCULATING.
YOU WOULD EXPECT OVER TIME THAT
CORONA WOULD REINFECT AND MAYBE
CAUSE COVID-19.
I THINK THE SURPRISING THING IS
THAT IT’S HAPPENING THIS
QUICKLY.
MANY FOLKS IN THE COUNTRY
VACCINATED SIX MONTHS AGO AND
WHAT WE ARE SEEING BREAKTHROUGH
CASES STARTING TO EMERGE
DIFFERENTLY ACROSS THE VACCINES
FOR SURE BUT REALLY STARTING TO
EMERGE AS A RESULT OF THE DELTA
VARIANT AT ABOUT 6 TO 9 MONTHS
AND THAT SUGGESTS WE WILL NEED
BOOSTER VACCINES TO GET THROUGH
THE WINTER.
MARIA: I WANT TO ASK YOU MORE
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I KNOW THE
VACCINE LOSES SOME EFFICACY
AFTER SIX MONTHS.
LET’S TAKE A SHORT BREAK AND
ZERO IN ON THE VACCINE EFFICACY
LONGER TERM AND I WANT TO ASK
YOU WHAT YOU’RE DEVELOPING WITH
THE MRN TECHNOLOGY INCLUDING
TREATING RESPIRATORY DISEASE AND
CANCERMENT WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK
>> NOW CDC AND THE PRESENT
ADMINISTRATION WON’T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE NATURAL IMMUNITY
WHICH IS EVERY BIT AS EFFECTIVE
AS GETTING THE VACCINATION AND
BETWEEN THE TWO ABOUT 85% OF OUR
POPULATION HAS IMMUNITY, SO WE
NEED TO BE DEALING WITH THAT AND
WORKING WITH THAT AND GIVING
PEOPLE THE ACTUAL NUMBERS AND
LETTING THEM MAKE DECISIONS,
MANDATE --
MARIA: AND THAT WAS DR. BEN
CARSON ON THE PROGRAM LAST MONTH
DISCUSSING NATURAL IMMUNITY.
HE, OF COURSE, IS A SPECIALIST
IN NEUROLOGY.
I’M BACK WITH DR. STEPHEN HOGE
FROM MODERNA.
DR. HOGE, HOW MUCH IMMUNITY DOES
A PERSON HAVE IF THEY’VE ALREADY
HAD COVID, WOULD THEY NEED A
BOLSTER SHOT AS WELL?
DOCTOR: WELL, I THINK WE DON’T
KNOW.
WE ARE STILL TRYING TO BUILD
DATA ON HOW MUCH NATURAL
IMMUNITY PROTECTS YOU JUST LIKE
WITH THE VACCINE.
WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE MEASURE THE
LEVEL OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
INFECTED IT IS LAWER THAN
CERTAINLY MODERNA VACCINE OR
PFIZER VACCINE WHICH WOULD
SUGGEST THAT BREAKTHROUGH CASES
ARE GOING TO HAPPEN WITH NATURAL
IMMUNITY AT LEAST AS SOON AS OR
SOONER THAN WITH VACCINES.
MARIA: THIS IS -- THIS IS
FASCINATING AND, OF COURSE, I
KNOW THAT WE ARE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THIS AS WE LIVE IT.
BUT YOU’RE SAYING THAT WE WILL
-- YOU’RE NOT SURPRISED BY THESE
BREAKTHROUGH CASES, RIGHT, BUT
YOU WERE SURPRISED YOU SAID A
MINUTE AGO THAT IT WAS HAPPENING
AS SOON AS IT WAS, RIGHT?
DOCTOR: THAT’S RIGHT.
I THINK YOU’D EXPECT RESPIRATORY
VIRUSES TO BE ABLE TO REINFECT
PEOPLE AND NOT CAUSE SEVERE
DISEASE LIKE COVID-19 BUT SORT
OF THE NATURAL HISTORY OF
INFECTIONS.
I THINK THE SURPRISING THING
THAT WE ARE ALL SEEING WE ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
AND THE VIRUS CONTINUES TO
EVOLVE AND GET MORE AGGRESSIVE
AND DELTA IS AN EXAMPLE OF HUGE
CHANGE IN ABILITY TO INFECT
PEOPLE.
AND SO WITH THAT CHANGE, WHAT
YOU’RE SEEING IS RAPID
BREAKTHROUGH.
THAT’S THE SURPRISING THING FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE.
THE DURABILITY OF THE FIRST
COUPLE OF SHOTS IS REALLY ONLY
LOOKING TO BE MAYBE SIX MONTHS,
MAYBE A YEAR.
NOW, THAT’S NOT TERRIBLY
SURPRISING THAT YOU WOULD NEED A
THIRD DOZE AS DR. HANH SAID,
THAT HAPPENS WITH TETANUS AND
FLU SHOT EVERY YEAR AND YOU NEED
THE BOOST YOUR LEVELS OF
IMMUNITY.
WE WERE HOPEFUL THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO STOP THIS THING WITH
INITIAL DOSES AND REQUIRE
BOLSTERS BROADLY CERTAINLY BY
THE FALL.
MARIA: SO I WANT TO LOOK AT
REALLY THE CONVERSATION TAKING
PLACE IN THE MEDICAL RESEARCH
COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW AND IN PART
OF THAT CONVERSATION HAS TO DO
WITH COMPARING THE LEADING
VACCINES.
THIS IS A STUDY WHICH WAS
REVIEWED BY THE MAYO CLINIC AND
WHAT IT SHOWS US WHILE BOTH
VACCINES WERE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
DURING THE PERIOD FROM JANUARY
TO JUNE, 1 MONTHS LATER IN TERMS
OF THE SEVENTH MONTH, THAT’S
JULY, THE NUMBERS ACTUALLY
DROPPED CONSIDERABLY AND WHAT
YOU HAVE IS EFFECTIVENESS
AGAINST INFECTION, CONSIDERABLY
LOWER FROM THE 90% AT MODERNA
AND GOES DOWN TO 75%, LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE PFIZER DRUG.
IT DROPS ALL THE WAY DOWN TO H
2%.
THIS STUDY SUGGESTS THAT THE
MODERNA VACCINE IS SUPERIOR TO
THE PFIZER VACCINE.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS NOT PEW
REVIEWED.
WE ARE WAITING PEW REVIEWS HERE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
STUDY?
>> FIRST CAVEAT THAT MODERNA IS
NOT INVOLVED, INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH, I THINK YOU SUMMARIZED
IT WELL.
THERE’S EMERGING EVIDENCE FROM
THE STUDY AND OTHER SOURCES THAT
THERE’S A DIFFERENCE IN THE
DURABILITY OF PROTECTION
PARTICULARLY IN THE FACE OF THE
DELTA VARIANT AT ABOUT 6 MONTHS
BETWEEN THE TWO DIFFERENT
VACCINES THAT ARE OTHERWISE VERY
SIMILAR.
I THINK THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE PUBLIC COMMENT BY BOTH OF
THE COMPANIES ABOUT THEIR PHASE
3 TRIALS RECENTLY AS WELL AS
SOME OTHER PUBLICATIONS
INTERNATIONALLY INCLUDING FROM
THE GOVERNMENTS AND CANADA
SHOWING A SLIGHT DIFFERENCE IN
PROTECTION OVER TIME.
I THINK THE ONE LAST THING THAT
I’D WANT TO SAY ABOUT IT, WHILE
THERE ISN’T MANY SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS AROUND THIS AND REALLY
THAT’S NOT THE PURSUE OF ANY
COMPANY, THE GENERAL SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY, EVEN IF THERE’S A
DIFFERENCE HERE AND THE MODERNA
VACCINE IS SHOWING BETTER
PROTECTION AGAINST THE VARIANT,
WE DON’T EXPECT THAT TO BE
PERMANENT.
THE TRUTH IS AS YOU POINTED OUT,
THERE’S A LITTLE BIT OF WANING
FROM MODERNA.
EVEN THOUGH IT LOOKS BETTER IT
IS TRENDING DOWN.
WE SUSPECT MAYBE AT A YEAR,
MAYBE LONGER, YOU WILL SEE
EVENTUAL INCREASE IN
BREAKTHROUGH CASES EVEN WITH THE
BEST VACCINES WHICH IS
ULTIMATELY BOOSTERS ARE THE BEST
WAY TO MAINTAIN BROAD POPULATION
IMMUNITY SO WE CAN STOP THE
PANDEMIC AND STOP THE ECONOMIC
DESTRUCTION AND CERTAINLY STOP
THE DEATH.
MARIA: IF YOU HAD TWO SHOTS OF
THE PFIZER, CAN YOU DO THE
MODERNA BOOSTER SHOT OR DO YOU
HAVE TO STICK WITH THE SAME?
>> WELL, THAT’S REALLY THE
DECISION FOR REGULATORS AND
PUBLIC OFFICIALS TO MAKE.
AS A COMPANY WE WILL GENERATE
DATA AND WE ARE CONDUCTING
CLINICAL STUDIES ACTUALLY
EXACTLY ON THAT WITH THE THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF HEALTH.
BUT THE CHOICE OF WHETHER THAT’S
APPROPRIATE IS REALLY UP TO FDA
AND THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CDC.
MARIA: AND -- AND DR. HOGE, I
KNOW THAT MODERNA HAS BEEN
DEVELOPING, WORKING ON MRNA
TECHNOLOGY FOR TEN YEARS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMPANY HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON AND
YOU ARE ALSO LOCKING TO APPLY
THAT TO OTHER ILLNESSES SUCH AS
OTHER RESPIRATORY DISEASE AS
WELL AS CANCER.
TELL US HOW YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
TAP IN MRNA TECHNOLOGY FOR OTHER
USES?
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WE ACTUALLY ARE WELL KNOWN FOR
OUR WORK AT COVID BUT FOR THE
LAST YEARS WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM TO TRY TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THE DISEASES THAT
YOU JUST REFERENCED.
IF YOU LOOK AT RESPIRATORY
DISEASE, WE NEED TO DO SO MUCH
BETTER IN PREVENTING THE DEATH
EVERY YEAR THAT HAPPENS AS A
RESULT OF INFECTIONS LIKE FLU OR
THE COMMON COLD VIRUSES THAT
OFTEN ACTUALLY LEAD TO SILENT
DEATH IN THE COUNTRY AND
INTERNATIONALLY.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD FOR
DEVELOPING SOLUTIONS FOR THAT.
HOPEFULLY SINGLE VACCINATION,
SINGLE INJECTION THAT WILL
PROTECT YOU AGAINST ALL VIRUSES
AND COVID-19 THAT LEAD YOU TO
DEATH AND DISABILITY.
BUT WE’VE ACTUALLY OBVIOUSLY
SUBSTANTIALLY PIVOTED TO FOCUS
ON COVID-19 FOR THE LAST YEAR
BUT WE HAVEN’T STOPPED THAT WORK
AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
STARTING LATE-STAGE STUDIES
ACROSS RANGE OF OTHER
RESPIRATORY VIRUSES.
SAME SORTS OF THING USING MRNA
SOMETHING TO DO WITH CANCER.
WE ARE RUNNING CLINICAL TRIALS
TRYING TO TEACH IMMUNE SYSTEM
WHAT YOUR CANCER LOOKS LIKE FOR
PERSON’S CANCER SO IMMUNE SYSTEM
CAN ATTACK AND HOPEFULLY REVERSE
IMMUNE AS WELL.
MARIA: AMAZING, AMAZING.